I got a question for you guys how many
holes are on my shirt thank the cats for
that we're gonna watch from mr. crup
cheese today he hit me up directly
asking me to cover this it's called what
our characters we love the edits that
this guy does so I was like hell yeah
let's get to it
[Music]
what are characters characters a good
human beings bad right and wrong kind
the Ryan Gosling strong we winners
hey mr. Widders strong becoming weak
weak becoming strong
they feel pain Julie this is already a
beautiful item Matthew yeah peaceful
we feel brave their fears their
different and alone they live
[Music]
I asked boiler water thank you
reflections of us exactly oh it's great
and I'm going to pain our pain our
addictions
our self-destructive behavior the fears
and anxiety and the courage to face them
mercilessly show
the price which used to hide
our violent acts and moments of madness
this movie
with regrets from an unfulfilled dream
we're choosing to follow your passion
until that dream
[Music]
that's true characters are who we are
they food who want to be
[Music]
living through I do want to be at a
driver for better store
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
what our characters do you hahaha very
well that man is beautiful very
well-constructed he's really thoughtful
it's interesting that you composed a
sort of like this video essay also a
tone poem based off of you know your
interpretation your personal one kind of
dissecting or analyzing or raising the
question of what our characters and yet
you don't have a character you're
focusing on directly like there's no you
know main character focal point or a
protagonist necessarily yet there still
is a little tail being told here a
journey in arc which is you know what
characters are so it's really cool that
you can post something together that
starts off with yeah raising the
questions and setting up a whole bunch
of different types of characters and
when you're talking about strong
becoming weak weak becoming strong the
different types of traits that everyone
has and then eventually you know you're
seeing that they all do evolve and
change that's a reflective experience my
personal take on characters it's like
you know from writing people are always
constantly saying you know the old
phrase is how do we make this character
likeable and I don't really agree with
that sentiment fully whoever your
character is I think in some way you use
the word reflection and I would say the
word relatable regardless of whether
you're focusing on the main character
being a hero anti hero or villain as the
main lead even if you don't like the
person you got to be able to understand
or somehow relate so in the were using
the word reflection kind of holding a
mirror up to oneself because you are
living cathartic ly through whoever the
character is I mean take a character
like Daniel day-lewis from there'll be
blood and in some ways it's like you can
judge and observe that character and in
other ways it could kind of bring out
living through that character the
internal read and lust form or as you're
experiencing it so I think regardless
characters are their job is to give the
audience and experience I really loved
your mantra of characters or who we are
and who we want to be because so many
characters do have these relatable
qualities and then the fantasy aspect of
movies
allow us to access this aspirational
place where you know through the
catharsis of a story and those emotions
in the representation of that through
writing and acting and all that stuff
like there's so much that goes into a
character as well as just whatever the
writer conceived and there is
collaboration around that and I really
love yeah the way that you chose this
medley of clips because it just really
got me caught up in the emotional state
of a each of the clips and be the
emotional impact of meaningful art as a
whole and I liked your point about this
being a tone poem in and of itself
because it really is it's very moving
and it seems like really I like that
point to make good point I like that
point you should start a channel or
something I think that that just really
hit the the nail on the head and I mean
you know there are poorly orchestrated
characters out there too one of the
things that has always struck me about
writing not that I am a very
accomplished writer but a lot of times
people puzzle on how to write characters
and one of the things that has helped me
the most is just the more you listen to
people and observe other people in your
life don't eavesdrop like a jerk but you
know if you just observe other people
you observe the situation's you're in
how people speak and respond some of the
best writing advice I feel like I've
ever received is just pay attention to
the people around because the greatest
characters just feel so quintessentially
like people and they hit your soul in
that way where you're like I know this
guy or I've been this person you know
yeah that's why I talk about
relatability because I think what a lot
of people kind of search for even
whether they realize it consciously or
subconsciously a feeling of expression
when you're living through a character
like growing up I used to kind of
identify as someone who felt rather
empty and not someone who could really
express yet when I would watch movies
and I think that's why film and
television meant so much to me I would
go through all these different emotional
experiences that in real life I didn't
really know how to express and that
doesn't necessarily just mean vocabulary
expression I think that's why a role
like Arthur flex Joker of last year or
the characters and parricide can hit
home even if we're not these people and
even though they're on the much darker
spectrum of characters to observe and
they're doing things we most likely
wouldn't do in real life there's a thing
of that feeling being communicated out
there that we get a live through it's a
different topic than how to make a
character likeable necessarily because
I've heard a great screenwriting tip
that I once got or I heard on a video of
from a channel called film courage was
for your for your main character the
easiest way to get audiences on board
for them find out what their their
emotional internal limit struggle is
whatever but they also have to have like
a physical goal in mind what do they
have to internally overcome that's like
you the audience gets focused on the
physical goal of what they got to
achieve but how will they change as a
human being by the time they get to that
physical goal whether that means they
devolve into something worse or they
have to overcome and grow and I think
that's why you know stories of weak
becoming strong are so you know such
audience crowd pleasers okay yeah
because a lot of times to achieve the
success that they're aiming for they
have to grow and believe in themselves
or something so I think that's why that
traditional storytelling still hits home
for a lot of people yeah and I like the
thing you ended with to just that
question of what our characters to you
because one of the most fascinating
things about characters and one of the
things that makes them most alive to me
is the fact that there are some
characters who I might incredibly
identify with who other people just
don't care for and there are especially
lots of movies that I personally like
about characters who are hard to relate
to and who are kind of abrasive and who
aren't the most easy to relate to on the
spot you know you need to peel them back
it's always a bummer when you you know
somebody's like I just don't like this
character I can't get into it when you
can but that's also the Rorschach test
of this art in general and especially
characters because it is painting with
emotion it's people it's it's all
expression in the most familiar way
possible for us at least what is a
character I think is something that's
alive and different to everybody and
that's the most wonderful thing about
you know the visual medium to me well
this was beautiful dude congratulations
I hope this video gets more views
because this is really thought-provoking
stuff a great film analysis would love
to see more like it but hold off on that
just do more like Black Widow and the
style of you know spies in this case
yeah
like that let's face it you need to get
that view count up so do more of those
trailer mashups and less of this stuff
I'll be thoughtful I don't want to learn
thoughtful isn't Sandler nning is not my
forte
anyway I subscribe to mr. crap just for
more videos like this subscribe for the
real rejects click that notification
about catch you guys on the
flippety-flip side of the flip
you